consciousness is perhaps the biggest
riddle in nature stripped to its core
meaning consciousness is what allows us
to be aware both of our surroundings and
of our own inner state but thinking
about consciousness has this habit of
taking us round in circles we all
intuitively know what consciousness is
it's this it's what you're experiencing
here right now but once we try to
pinpoint just what exactly it is it
leaves us grasping at thin air and not
just us philosophers and scientists
struggle to define consciousness
different schools and ideas compete with
one another but no one has come close to
figuring it out it's unsettling to
realize that we don't understand what
makes us aware of ourselves and the
world in this fuzzy area consciousness
and intelligence are also related
although they are not the same we'll
talk in greater depth about theories of
consciousness and intelligence in other
videos like much of what makes us human
our consciousness is likely to have
evolved from less complex forms as a
product of evolution by natural
selection it has probably emerged from
an immense several hundreds of million
years sequence of countless micro steps
that together make up a sort of gradient
of consciousness what was the first step
on this path from the non conscious to
the basic consciousness that ultimately
led to the convoluted consciousness we
humans enjoy today
[Music]
take a stone the consensus is that a
stone
is not conscious though not everyone
agrees even on this some pants.i kists
claimed that a lump of rock may have an
inner life however there are no real
grounds for any such assumption since
stones never show behaviour their inner
life can neither be proven nor disproven
a more common starting point is with the
living things a living thing or a self
is a part of the universe that sustains
itself and makes more of its kind to do
so it needs energy and this is where an
awareness of the world comes in handy
the original function of consciousness
was probably to direct a mobile self
that was short of energy to a fresh
supply of food on the smaller scales of
life you don't need to be aware to find
food trigger plaques adherents one of
the simplest of all animals moves around
haphazardly it slows down in the
presence of food and speeds up in its
absence this is highly effective and
makes the tiny creature spend more time
where there is food than where there is
not but it never moves in a particular
direction towards a particular target
and there's no need for it to be
conscious of its environment the first
major step towards consciousness was
probably taken when mobile selves start
to move themselves directionally moving
towards what was good for them safe food
and away from what was less good say
someone else who thought that they were
food
take Nagisa to Greener a tiny worm known
for its funny face sometimes the worm is
hungry and sometimes not this means that
when it moves the worm self is not
simply producing an automatic response
to an external stimulus but that its
actions depend upon its inner
physiological state whether it's hungry
or saint's it when it's just eaten the
worm is less energetic but when starved
for a while it will move itself in the
direction of tasty things it uses
chemoreceptors on its head to smell its
environment and guide it in the
direction whether scent of food is
strongest after finding and eating a
meal our worm buddy heads back to a dark
sheltered spot to digest it in safety
until it's hungry again but animals that
blindly follow their sense of smell
don't have a concrete objective in view
they still lack any sense of where they
are heading so the next step on the
ladder of consciousness is to add some
perception at a distance like vision
vision adds context and depth to our
world with vision comes a sense of the
space we and our food exist in it adds a
whole new dimension to awareness and is
a huge step towards more familiar
consciousness an optical apparatus like
an eye enables us to visualize our goal
and lock on to it but even at this stage
a self is only able to pursue its food
as long as it sees it so the next
logical step needs to happen on the
inside to visualize food in its absence
for example a self needs to create some
sort of inner representation of the
world
now an animal can continue looking for
food even when it escapes its sensory
range because of this inner
representation of what is relevant in
the world it can remain focused on its
food and its desire to get it our self
now exists in a world it can get
familiar with the ability to remember
things has emerged
thanks to memory animals can be
distracted from a pursuit for a few
seconds but quickly continue their path
afterwards a related phenomenon is
called object permanence this describes
our awareness that things continue to
exist even when we can't see them this
cognitive skill is enjoyed by some
mammals and birds than perhaps other
animals too human babies tend to develop
this ability around the time they turn
eight months while baby chickens show
this ability within a day or two of
being born the capacity to remember a
thing in its absence suggests at least a
basic sense of time a sense of time is a
big step on the ladder of consciousness
it may also enable itself to look
forward from the present moment and
anticipate the future adult chickens for
example are able to resist a meal put in
front of them if they expect to receive
a bigger meal as a prize for holding
back for a while this sort of delayed
gratification means there is an ability
to visualize a reward that only exists
in the future which can be quite a
challenge even for adult humans Western
scrub jays are experts in delayed
gratification they shown even more
elaborate sense of the future when they
hide food in a cache to retrieve it at a
later date the scrub jays will even
rehydrate
if they become aware that a potential
thief has been watching them this means
that they know that there are other
hungry selves out there who are aware
and see the world from their own
different perspective
crafty scrub jays can sort of read the
mind of their fellow birds this ability
to mind-read is crucial for complex
levels of consciousness by putting
yourself in the position of others you
can outsmart a rich competitor or
empathize with a hungry friend language
takes the ability to read minds and
represent what is absent to a whole new
level words enable us to construct
hypotheses about the world make detailed
plans and to communicate them with
others words enable us to think about
ourselves and our place in the universe
and even about our own consciousness
which is something we'll be doing more
in future videos so what is the origin
of our consciousness it probably began
as the directed motion of a hungry self
towards a source of food with the
survival benefits this gave it over
competitors that moved at random or not
at all it probably all started with the
urge for more food so even with the
sophisticated consciousness that allows
us to dream about space build
skyscrapers or obsess about novels it's
not surprising that we can't stop
thinking about where we'll get our next
meal collectively we've put so much
thought and ingenuity into getting food
that we can now just get our food to
come to us with little conscious effort
this video is part one of a three-part
video series relating to big questions
of life and the universe made possible
by a grant from the Templeton world
charity foundation you can find our
sources and further reading in the video
description or get the consciousness
book by Rupert Glasgow for free link
down below if you want to help us make
more videos you can do so on patreon.com
or get one of our posters from our shop
[Music]
you